let's talk about all my life the first
song you wanted to play
on the siriusxm new foo fighters channel
why is that why is this song
more important than any other song as an
opener
it's always been the best opening song
it just is it's like the theme from jaws
it's like
like if you start doing that in front of
a big arena it's like it's a suspenseful
sort of build up into this thing that
just goes
all right here it is foo fighters all my
life
here we go
[Music]
feel emotes feel it come to life
[Music]
another reason to please
[Music]
[Music]
another one
[Music]
and if you
[Music]
[Music]
everybody
[Music]
ways
[Music]
[Music]
all my life i've been searching for
something something never comes
nothing satisfies
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
that's why i want to learn how to play
the [ __ ] guitar i got to get in a
band already this is i'm i'm wasting
time i wish i could have fun
how much time do you think it'll take
you to get up to speed
ten thousand hours i don't have ten
thousand hours
i'm telling you that is magnificent